i like to ask this question every time
that i come here
every time i come and make sure that i
finish that sentence
because i know the people who come to
see my shows and
somebody who's going to call me that was
anybody here a few years back
when i was here and those people were
fingering each other
at the table were you at that show
you were the show after was anyone at
that show
yeah so first of all you were at that
show
you were here first of all it happened
at that table no pressure but
uh we're all looking for a little
entertainment from you guys so
it was the crate was it one of the
craziest
it was like one of the reasons i love
coming here
is because every time i come here
something really [ __ ] weird happens
and i love we weird [ __ ] i love it i
love it i love it
so just so you know no pressure but
here's what happened okay
by the way man good hair look at this
guy
holy [ __ ] my god not a hair out of place
a little bit hanging down i like it
do you do a hair flip in the morning or
no do you tell me
tell me tell me i have terrible jufrow
hair i've never been able to do a hair
flip in my life
i go like this and my hair goes like
that you know
[Laughter]
so you yeah you got is this your
girlfriend sister
wife i don't know i don't know i'm in
utah i don't know
your friend friend and who's this behind
you here
that's your girlfriend and that is
your your girlfriend's father is here
i think i can speak for all the fathers
when i tell you he doesn't trust you
[ __ ]
[Applause]
are you going out to a comedy show i'm
coming what all right
yeah i'm going to come home right next
to my daughter um
and so how does how do you fit in that's
your best friend
so your girlfriend brought her best
friend and her father on the date with
you
[Applause]
what's that he bought the tickets how
long have you guys been dating
six months you know what's crazy you've
been together six months
you've been together 21 years can i tell
you something they said something to
each other on a car ride over that would
end your [ __ ] relationship
you know there is a level of honesty at
this table you guys don't even
know anything about hey sometime this
week one of you two looked at the other
was like i [ __ ] hate you
so much and the other one was like i
don't give a [ __ ] whatever come on let's
go
you're not going anywhere
she still has to pretend to like
everything you do oh that's so funny
wow okay so he bought the tickets
for you or for the two of you how did
that work for her and then okay
all right well sir i didn't know if i
don't know if you if on purpose did you
spend extra for the finger bang table or
was that
were you like where do they finger bang
what is the
part of the floor where there's going to
be some finger banging happening because
let's see if we can ruin this six month
relationship by the end of this show
i mean i got 50 minutes i'm pretty good
at this
i'm going to tell you guys what happened
i'll tell you what
happened so
tell me and i may i may forget something
so if you can think of a pertinent part
of the story raise your hand you know
and i'll uh ignore you um so um
no so i'm sitting here and
there were four people at this table two
couples and i thought they were together
but you know the so say you and the
friend you were the couple and you were
facing me
and the other two were also facing me
but behind them and the
when i s because somebody said well how
did you know
he was finger banger and
you can attest to this guys he wasn't
subtle it wasn't
they were sitting almost as far apart as
you two were
and the best way i can describe it
it he looked like a dj scratching a
record like
[Applause]
there was zero subtlety in his movement
he didn't give a [ __ ] that anybody
else was here
now one of the wait staff asked me after
the show
how come you didn't say anything and i
will tell you the truth
it just gave me something different to
look at you know what i mean
i'm so used to seeing this when i was
like okay i'll look at that for a little
while
and it was right in front of me and he
was making eye contact with me and i was
like
this dude is a baller he's just like
what man what i'm like nothing dude
nothing it was a [ __ ] real prison
move you know what i mean like
now he did end up getting kicked out he
got kicked out
he got kicked out because he was talking
to the table and i can't have that
yeah listen your finger and your
girlfriend you're not bothering anybody
else you know what i mean
it's not disruptive to the show but
talking at your table is so
just so you know for the future if you
come to my shows finger blast away but
keep it down
so i ended up kicking him out and i
think we named him the finger bangers
didn't we on mr and mrs fingerbanger
and um so they're walking out and the
guy turned out to be a real [ __ ]
yeah he was angry um um and so
i got to tell you something that i found
out after the show
remind me okay i'm not going to tell you
after the show i found out after
i'll tell you okay so the guy
they walk out and i'm just like did
nobody
else see that because they were in wide
open like this
and about sixty percent of the crowd was
like no
[Applause]
and we had a good laugh and now the
couple who was sitting behind him
i had to ask because the i thought they
were together i go oh you guys weren't
together
and the woman goes no i can't believe i
had to sit at this table
and the guy goes i can't believe i
didn't have to pay extra for the ticket
[Applause]
how about this you know what i found out
after
they split up after they were both
on a secret date the reason he was mad
is either they were both married to
somebody else or both dating other
people
so he was mad because i put him on blast
but you can't come up in public and
finger bang your mistress
in front of four keep it down man i'm
trying to be subtle like no
bro you're wiki wiki not you know what i
mean
what uh no pressure um
dad you should sit this one out but uh
you know what i'm saying
he's like i can't believe i bought
tickets for this [ __ ] show and i sat
at this table
[Music]
[Music]
you